The first statement is false.
All problems solvable in exponential time by a deterministic RAM
take polynomial time on a nondeterministic RAM. This is not true.
There are problems that would still take exponential time on both a deterministric RAM
and a nondeterministric RAM.
For example, if you wanted to find every sublist of a list.
This is going to exponential time even on a nondeterministic RAM.
The second statement is also false,
because if randomized algorithms could solve some NP-complete problems,
let's say vertex cover, in expected polynomial time, well by the definition of NP-completeness
then we could reduce any other NP-complete problem to vertex cover
and then solve that in expected polynomial time.
There's no evidence that this is actually the case.
The final statement is true.
If P≠NP, then there are some NP-complete problems that don't have constant-factor
approximation algorithms that can run in polynomial time.
The reason for this is actually the converse.
We know that if we can find a constant-factor approximation algorithm
that runs in polynomial time for any NP-complete problem, then that implies that P=NP.